[Musique]
mais la dette on parle de 150 mille
enfants donc amérindiens métis et inuits
qui ont été envoyés dans ces pensionnats
comment ça s'est passé le début de cette
politique
coloniale a été de devenir un territoire
étranger sans le consentement des
parents et les arachides leur territoire
pour les amis dans d'autres régions
dindo province très très loin l'objectif
était de tuer les aider dans leur fin
juin justement 182 tombes anonymes ont
été à découverte sur le site d'un ancien
pensionnat à cranbrook en colombie
britannique a c'est la troisième
découverte de ce type en un mois on
parle ici de génocide de politique
génocidaire ça va au delà de la culture
mais plutôt un crime contre
l'humanité observe une nation
[Musique]
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terroriste de l'est ce que
vous êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pas du tout c'était attendu
de toute façon on savait que les
talibans étaient en train de revenir sur
le terrain depuis déjà des années ce qui
a été balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans
c'est al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001
et al qaïda et des talibans ce ne sont
pas deux concepts superposables comment
va vivre le peuple afghan dans les
semaines qui viennent on va assister à
un raz-de-marée humanitaire absolument
sans précédent y va y avoir des que non
pas seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là il est bien évident que la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
c'est notre devoir moral que de venir en
aide à ce peuple qui a souffert tant par
le passé
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire les éoliennes sont sujettes
à controverse en france on se demande
même parfois si elles sont aussi
écologiques qu'on le croit mais c'est en
mer dans la baie de saint brieuc qu'elle
cristallise aujourd'hui les oppositions
un vaste chantier est installé à 16
kilomètres des côtes bretonnes soixante
deux éoliennes doivent être construites
destinées à produire de l'électricité
pour 832 mille habitants mais tout le
monde n'est pas d'accord notamment les
parents pêcheurs pour en débattre nous
avons invité deux bretons ils sont
d'ailleurs en direct de bretagne le
premier c'est michel canet vais vous
êtes sénateur centriste du finistère en
juillet 2018 quand le sénat a donné son
feu vert à la construction d'éoliennes
sur les îles de sein est doué sondés
rejoint par la même occasion à la loi
littoral c'était d'un à la demande de
deux élus bretons dont vous argument que
c'est ils étaient principalement
alimentée en électricité par des groupes
électrogènes fonctionnant encore au
fioul aujourd'hui vous êtes favorable à
l'installation du parc éoliens marins
dans la baie de saint brieuc pouvez nous
dire pourquoi en deux trois phrases ben
oui bien sûr tout simplement bonsoir
tout d'abord la france est engagée à
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique qui à produire de l'énergie
renouvelable notamment pour éviter la
consommation d'énergies fossiles et bien
je crois qu'il faut que l'on bat les
moyens pour cela une énergie éolienne
doit y contribuer alain coudray ancien
patron pêcheur président depuis 2012 du
comité départemental des pêches et des
élevages marins des côtes d'armor êtes
devenu le porte parole des 800 marins
pêcheurs qui se dressent contre le
projet de parc éolien dans la baie de
saint brieuc vaut aussi pour vous pouvez
nous dire en quelques mots pour quelles
raisons
à l'horizon la première raison c'est que
nous ne puis 2012 on pose on pose des
questions aux porteurs de projets
si ça n'impacte eura pa notre métier on
attend toujours ses réponses on a des
données mais pas suffisamment et puis
voilà 2 comment dirais-je c'est une
c'est une beck était protégé depuis des
années est on en train de détruire le
travail de
de la pêche costarmoricaine mais
justement alors le promoteur cl marine
vous avez négocié avec le promoteur vous
avez obtenu des modifications quand même
alain coudray non voilà vous par les
promoteurs aujourd'hui promoteur cl
marines et plus n'est plus canon
aujourd'hui c'est iberdrola parce que l
marines était d'essayer des sociétés
françaises qui étaient dedans maintenant
il ya qu une seule société iberdrola
donc j'ai trouvé une entreprise
espagnole voilà une entreprise espagnole
bien connu dans tous les pays d'europe
et du monde
et on a obtenu des choses les choses
qu'on a surtout obtenu c'est entre 2007
et 2010 que jean yves le drian a créé là
comment la
la la commission mérite régional mer et
littoral où on a discuté avec la région
et les services de l'état euh là
aujourd'hui à ce moment là il y avait
aucun porteurs de projets
c'était vous remplir l'appel d'offres et
la profession a choisi de discuter
plutôt que de dire non et de laisser
faire faire n'importe quoi n'importe
n'importe où parce que ce qui s'est
passé que ces zones là qu'ont été décidé
à l'époque c'est que après des études
[Musique]
profonde de où allaient les pêcheurs
d'occupation de l'ue terrain villeray à
l'époque lie avec cinq six bateaux et
travailler dans cette zone et comme l'a
dit tout à l'heure le sénateur il
parlait du réchauffement climatique mais
le réchauffement climatique qui ment
climatique n'a pas que des inconvénients
il en a bien sûr mais il y en a d'autres
et des bonnes choses et dans la poupe à
l'heure actuelle dans la baie de saint
brieuc le réchauffement climatique
c'est-à-dire le réchauffement de l'eau
apportée une un changement de biomasse
exploitables de plusieurs espèces qui se
sont reproduits puisque depuis une
dizaine d'années le lot s'est réchauffée
2e degré 5 ce qui a favorisé plus notre
gestion ont fait de la coquille saint
jacques une comment dirais-je une très
grosse pêcheries de coquilles saint
jacques en hiver ou de ses
ressortissants finistériens savent bien
venir travailler chez nous voilà il a
récolté de travail c'est que cela a mûri
qu'un entre parenthèses
on a les seins coudray on reviendra sur
les poissons mais je voulais faire
réagir nice et le cannet vais justement
sur le promoteur alors que ce soit elle
marine ou iberdrola et effectivement ça
jette la suspicion de la part de
beaucoup d'associations et pas seulement
qu'en est il en ce qui vous concerne
moi j'en ai pas puisque il ya eu un
appel à projets et donc des concurrents
qui ont soumissionné
l'attention du gouvernement n'était pas
d'attribuer l'ensemble des projets à eux
mêmes porteurs de projets de façon à
faciliter la réalisation et c'est ainsi
qu' effectivement c'est elle la reine a
racheté ensuite par amour de capitaux et
iberdrola qui effectivement obtenu le
l'appel à projets moi je dirais que
berlin est une société européenne et
aujourd'hui il faut que l'on raisonne à
l'échelle européenne si l'on veut
vraiment appréhender ces questions
puisque nous vendons de l'électricité à
d'autres pays européens l'espagne et
l'irlande de puisqu'un un projet
d'encours aussi pour relier les revendre
à la france et donc on voit bien que la
croche à l'aide européenne aujourd'hui
donc je crois qu'il faut pas avoir
d'états d'âme sur la question de
l'origine du promoteur appartement elle
est européenne le chantier a été lancé
au mois de mai alors qu'il ya encore de
multiples recours juridique
alors le chantier a été lancé c'est vrai
au mad men mais des instances juridiques
des recours dès qu'il y en a des
quantités qui ont été menées il faut
rappeler que le promoteur a été choisi
en 2012 nous sommes neuf ans après a
commencé des travaux il n'est pas
possible que l'on continue ainsi en
france il faut que l'on simplifie les
choses car demain si l'on veut que l'on
ait de la production d'énergies
renouvelables il faut que les projets
puissent se concrétiser bien plus
rapidement on voit bien que les
conditions économiques changent en
permanence et s'il faut attendre autant
de temps ce n'est pas possible pour
pouvoir réaliser des projets qui sont
importants pour notre avenir
est la coudraie
vous avez
vous même engagé à s'entendre de recours
juridiques du moins les avocats que vous
avez engagé et y compris devant le parc
parc national financier d'ailleurs
on avait ça dernièrement on a fait faire
ça d'aider dernièrement mais quand quand
j'entends par les sénateurs jeu je me
demande s'il connaît bien le projet
lorsque comme engrais parce que ça se
passe pas du tout ça c'est pas ça se
passe pas du tout comme ça c'est c'est
ça c'est dans le meilleur des mondes et
comme nous sommes dans les meilleurs des
mondes pas déjà comment dirais-je qu'on
vous dise tu es le marigny iberdrola bas
iberdrola s'est
et ces européens mais il faut regarder
les casseroles qui traîne la réputation
nous on a joué franchement on a
travaillé avec au début avant 2017 avec
une équipe de l'équipe je dirais elle
elle marine mais depuis 2007 on est
l'équipe l'iberdrola est là aujourd'hui
c'est plus des gens qu'on négocie si on
nous envoie des mercenaires quand on
parle de vous parler des travaux qui ont
commencé en mai
si vous deviez bien être au courant un
peu de ce qui s'est passé à saint
nazaire et bien le programme des travaux
de saint nazaire les discussions ont
duré trois ans
dans le parc de saint brieuc il n'y a
pas une seule réunion pour préparer le
chantier pour avoir des accords d époque
2d certaine époque pour travailler plus
ou moins commencé avril mai juin discuté
par rapport au travail des bateaux ça il
ya eu aucune discussion
normalement elle mais elle elle marine
iberdrola doit fournir un comment
dirais-je un programme trois mois avance
au service de l'état ça n'a jamais été
fait jamais
voilà il ya beaucoup de choses comme ça
qu'ils n'ont pas c'est pour ça que nous
nous sommes trop colère c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on est rentré en justice
depuis le mois de juillet et par an les
secondes avant
non mais une instance en justice a été
introduite auprès du parquet national
financiers pour considérer que la le
projet serait sur rémunérés moi même je
suis producteur d'énergie dans le sens
auch sur ma maison j'ai un petit projet
photovoltaïque et je vends mon énergie à
60 centimes puisque j'ai signé le
contrat il ya un peu plus de 11 ans or
vous savez bien j'achète l'énergie en
heures creuses à tous santé mais en
heures pleines à 16 centimes donc je
vends bien plus cher que
que je n'achète aujourd'hui mais il
fallait lancer
la filière photovoltaïque est
aujourd'hui ceux qui s'installent au
point de du photovoltaïque et le fonds à
des conditions bien moins attractive que
celle dont j'ai bénéficié puisque
aujourd'hui c'est à 19 centimes du
kilowatt on voit bien que pour lancer
des filières il faut qu'il n'y ait quand
même des précurseurs il faut qu'il y ait
un certain qu'ils entreprennent et ceci
explique qu'il y ait une sur
rémunération qui d'ailleurs en la
circonstance a été revue à la baisse par
rapport au projet initial de 2012
ce chantier il peut s'arrêter un il
suffit que que là il se trouve que le
sol est rocheuse là où ils sont en train
de creuser c'est pas du sable comme dans
la mer du nord si c'est trop dur ça va
s'arrêter alain coudray
je sais pas encore on voit la vitesse ça
avance on se pose des questions on se
pose de grandes questions voilà et
savoir tout à l'heure je vais répondre
un peu aux sénateurs qui parle du prix
de l'électricité à savoir c'est que la
compensation du prix qui va être payé
qui c'est qui va les payer ça va être
les français ou les européens
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut lire et
comment
on verra bien la facture on verra bien
la facture
ce qui nous embête le plus nous c'est au
nom de réchauffement climatique en
premier et deuxièmement que la bretagne
on ne n'est pas auto suffisance en
production électrique
je lui dit autre chose moi je suis
breton fier d'être breton je défends ma
nationalité
bretonne pour dire même et je vous dis
une chose monsieur c'est que on produit
pas d'électricité mais en produits de
l'alimentaire
et ont fourni à des gens qui sont
stressés comme cette année avec que kovy
de 19 qui sont venus par milliers sur
nos côtes
aujourd'hui on leur vend du rêve on leur
rend la mer le rêve plus loin allez
prochaine si c'est le parquet fait on
leur vendre à une zone industrielle en
mer parce que là on veut un lustre à guy
industrialisés les côtes françaises
c'est à dire que maintenant la personne
qui aura travaillé toute sa vie toute
son année dans une zone industrielle
il revient en vacances il sera toujours
sur la plage il sera toujours dans une
zone industrielle
voilà ce que voilà ce qu'on va la sq on
entre à le faire en train de tuer notre
bretagne
michel quint et v l'argument de
l'esthétique revient en permanence quand
on parle de l'éolien alors c'est très
subjectif mais c'est vrai que personne
n'est très très heureux à l'idée que
dans la baie de saint brieuc tout à
couillet 62 éoliennes si proche des
côtes
oui alors on a installé sur le
territoire national à terre un certain
nombre d'éoliennes et on voit bien que
cela suscite
des résistances sont pas tout simplement
parce que beaucoup veulent l'énergie
propre mais personne ne veut des halls
yen à côté de chez lui ici on parle de
champ éolien qui sont à près de 20
kilomètres du littoral alors c'est vrai
qu'on les verra c'est exactement 14 ans
et 80 c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'on les verra un tout petit
peu mais la visibilité sur un quand même
un peu réduite et donc je pense que
l'acceptabilité en mer les conditions
d'exploitation en mer sont bien
meilleurs que ce littoral je veux dire
par là que la productivité des éoliennes
sera sans doute bien meilleur en mer ici
on parle d'un projet vous l'avais dit
dans votre propos liminaire qui vise à
alimenter la production énergétique
d'électricité de plus deux de plus que
le département des côtes d'armor 800
plus de huit cent mille habitants
c'est à dire qu'on a besoin d'eux en
bretagne aussi et bien de pouvoir
produire de l'énergie c'est vrai qu'on a
des ressources paris mais légal purisme
mais on voit bien partout il ya des
éoliennes je suis dans le finistère où
il ya des des parts et des divers partir
lien cela n'entame en rien du tout la
présence de visiteurs de tourisme qui
s'accommode tout à fait de la présence
d'éoliennes sur certains territoires
du finistère donc on peut concilier les
usages et c'est un peu l'objectif qui
est visé ici à la coudraie bon d'accord
si sur le paysage csu est certes mais
nous le pêcheur là là là j'ai attaqué le
paysage parce que pour répondre à ce que
disait le sénateur mais aujourd'hui nous
en baie de saint brieuc on a 300 bateaux
300 bateaux de dont 220 coquille et les
craintes se sont acoquinés là c'est
quasiment deux des trois départements
des ouattara n'y voit la tendance à
prendre pendant l'hiver il travaille on
a protégé on a géré on a géré 7,7
comment cette baie mais exemplaire on
est cité on est cité on est invité à des
colloques internationale j'en ai assisté
a en commande à londres voilà par
rapport à notre gestion d'un quotidien
aujourd'hui une
une bonne très bonne gestion il ya à
pêcher
il ya de la production il ya de la vente
il ya 20 ans on a fait une usine avec
les pêcheurs et à l'industriel voilà on
est organisés et aujourd'hui on ne veut
pas nous répondre s'il y aura un impact
bien sûr il ya eu des études de bruit
qui a été fait
à comment havre est
bien sûr comme dit le scientifique
la bruine ne tue pas la coquille non
mais la fatigue voilà et l'impact de la
fatigue ben il y aura des prix il ya des
prédateurs qui viennent l'altruisme la
quantité qui seront gratuites on ne le
connaît pas parce que les essais ont été
faits en bassin voilà la copie bombe à
chaque bruit elle s'ouvre et fatigue son
muscle au bout d'un certain temps on
aura
quel est le résultat on ne sait pas moi
ça fait 30 ans je travaille sur la
coquille 30 ans avec mes collègues pour
amener on a fait de la gestion d'assurer
leur en font pas un avion du finistère
1 qui vient surveillée pendant la
pêcherie une gestion très bonne gestion
et le remerciement une profession
qui est exemplaire qui fait un travail
exemplaire on lui met
un parc éolien mais ces jeunes là chez
moi qui ont investi c'est 800 marins clé
voir si on en perd la moitié 400 marins
ou qui sait où est ce que vous allez
mettre à travailler où est-ce qu'ils
vont aller il n'y a pas assez les gars
n'y a pas assez de chemin en bretagne et
à l'est et nous au contraire on
recherche de l'emploi on crée de
l'emploi on crée de l'emploi le
département des côtes d'armor
aujourd'hui on est au maximum au niveau
au niveau gestion pêche on ne peut plus
prendre de bateaux parce que ça on se
dit que si on en rajoute 3 4 5 la
production
la ressource ne l'a comment dirais je ne
peux pas te permettre alors aujourd'hui
nous ont fait là on a fait l'effort et
aujourd'hui on vient nous embêter avec
un parc éolien
et sao nous parce que la voix de la
bretagne ne produit pas d'électricité
mais voilà je ccc ccc incompréhensif
nous sommes en bretagne michel canet vcc
soixante deux éoliennes
dont l'impact est c'est vrai à
prévisible on ne sait pas ce que ça va
donner
est ce que ça vaut la peine de perdre
les coquilles saint jacques on en aura -
et des pêcheurs qu'euro moins d'emplois
alors frédéric taddeï soyons clairs moi
j'adore la copie saint-jacques et je
veux saluer la démarche des pêcheurs de
la baie de saint brieuc elle est
formidable en termes d'exemplarité pour
ce qui concerne la préservation et la
gestion de la ressource il n'ya pas ya
quasiment pas d'équivalent de démarches
si je dirais à ses nuits est telle que
celle là simplement moi je pense que
l'on peut consigner l'ensemble des
enjeux le tout est effectivement ce parc
éolien ne soit pas sur les zones les
plus denses e pour la coquille elles ne
sont en aucune aucune des éoliennes
prévues nez sur la zone primaire d' de
la coquille saint jacques une partie 15%
serait sur la zone secondaire
c'est-à-dire là où il y a que moi de the
office agen mais finalement moi je me
dis que les récifs c'est à dire ce que
l'on peut mettre en mer des zones dans
lesquelles
il faut limiter la pêche ça peut être
extrêmement prolifique pour la gestion
de la ressource aussi puisque ça permet
d'avoir des autres ou la région
justement peut se reproduire le plus
facilement et ainsi faire en sorte que
la la ressource soit plus abondante de
match quoique il faut vraiment que l'on
gère comme ça mais mais disons le
clairement
l'essentiel du parc éolien n'affecte pas
les zones de pêche comprennent
l'ensemble des pêcheurs de la coquille
saint jacques sur la baie de saint
brieuc alain coudray du chèque n -b
parle de l'effet récifs sur les sur les
éoliennes vous y croyez euh je vais
l'inviter à aller sur le site de comment
dirais-je de l'ifremer pour voir les
résultats des campagnes qui font en mer
du nord le long des parcs éoliens et des
commandes et les commandes et puits de
pétrole et cette année ils sont même
allés du côté du côté à la sortie de la
tamise et vous verrez les rapports ce
qui les a empêchés et après midi mais
pourra me téléphoner si nous avons
besoin de compter les phones je veux
bien me donner et pourra me dire si si
ça réfère à 6
à les voir aller voir sur le site de
l'ifremer vous verrez bien et vous serez
peut-être surpris
les études le domaine des études
scientifiques des études scientifiques
ont été réalisés ici à la circonstance
et ont montré que l'impact serait
extrêmement réduit sur la ressource donc
je pense à un inventaire a déjà été fait
sur ce plan là et qu'il ya déjà des
éléments scientifiques qu'ils ont été
communiqués
now qu'il ya eu aucune donnée
scientifique
qui existent aujourd'hui qui a été fait
voilà il ya que y'a même pas de
bibliographie c'est-à-dire gao qui n'ait
aucune étude qui était fait sur le
poisson aucune aucune eau qu'il occulte
tout simplement souvent qu'eux mêmes
même si même si on avait une on l'a
posée à iberdrola et comme comme si bien
fait c'est c'est cette mafia que que je
peux je n'ai pas peur de le dire
j'assume c'est que à chaque parc éolien
ce n'est pas le même consortium et ça
veut dire ceux qui étaient ceux qui
étudié les résultats des études comme
c'est un corse consortium sa degré
secrets industriels
si vous vous dites le contraire je veux
bien amenez moi le papier voilà moi ça
fait dur et ça fait dix ans dix ans que
je ne connaissais égaler voire à cacher
une mission spécialement embauchés pour
ça on n'a aucun retour d'expérience sur
l'impact le seul retour d'expérience
qu'on a c'est laisser les données de
pêcheurs professionnels 1 quand on va
prendre les grands pays aux liens
hollandais c'est que des gros bateaux
qui viennent dans la manche péché delà
du poisson de l'épauler farine en
belgique il ya quoi il devait voir 40
bateaux de 40 bateaux en allemagne y en
a pas il doit ya un ou deux voilà n'y
aurait que d'armor on est 300 les jeux a
envoyé un c'est pas pareil et c'est de
la pêche côtière
et ne innova nos bateaux ne sont pas
faits pour aller ils sont et elise ont
été étudiés les gens ont investi pour
travailler dans notre belle île sont pas
étudiés pourrait pour aller dans le
milieu de la manche
il ya un gagnant et une catégorie de
pêcheurs à elle est autorisée il y en a
une trentaine dans l'est d'amore qui
vont pêcher qui vont pêcher rendez dans
les eaux britanniques voilà mais les
bateaux nos bateaux côtier de nos ports
de 5 à erquy 5 et paimpol loguivy pors
even tout ça c'est des bateaux coach et
c'est des petits bateaux et voilà et
chaque petit bateau ben on est on est on
est on est dans le dans le dans la mode
actuelle des petits bateaux qu'ils vont
leur production en direct voilà nous bon
bah voilà les pêcheront label la
pêcherie le coquillier et comment
dirais-je est quand même énorme chez
nous puisque ont une marée de 45 minutes
on va vous débarquez 150 tonnes à 200
tonnes de coquilles en 45 minutes avec
220 bateaux ben on n'arrive pas avant de
tout qu'est ce qu'on fait on a créé une
usine qui la décortique qui la vend
décortiqué surgelés frais tout voilà
voilà nous on s'est organisé aujourd'hui
à l'appel et les marins d'abel saint
brieuc se sont organisés depuis les
années 90 on s'est organisé et
aujourd'hui parce que hein iberdrola
venir le beh on veut casser toute
l'organisation des effets
il s'agit pas de casser de
l'organisation exige maintenant
fortement pour dire que ce n'est qu'une
petite partie de la zone secondaire là
où c'est le moins productif de la
coquille saint-jacques que le parc
éolien s'implante ce n'est pas là où
l'essentiel de l'affreux tu y vas
effectivement péché je prends une autre
illustration ne veut pas de notre hymne
et rational vous plaît ce que vous venez
de dire vous l'avez la deuxième fois
vous le dit et moi je vous réponde
cette zone que vous dites la deuxième
seconde beau jaune secondaire vous savez
ce que c'est cette deuxième seconde zone
se modère c'est le deuxième gisement
breton après notre premier premier rôle
dans notre moteur dans d'autres zones
secondaires il ya plus de coquilles à
roscoff qu en rade de brest co glénan
etc à quiberon
les galets les commandes de notre
jugement secondaires je vais chez mes
collègues de quiberon qui me disent si
seulement on pourrait avoir une biomasse
aussi grande que celle là voilà le mais
ce que je les chiffres que moi je vous
donne ils sont vérifiables avec
l'ifremer parce que nous depuis 40 ans
on travaille avec les scientifiques
disent première entre le mans en ce
moment ils sont en train de faire les
comme les prospections pour savoir ce
qu'on va pouvoir pêcher voilà ça fait 40
ans monsieur qu on fait ça on sait pour
ça vous dire nous on peut vous dire ce
qui a sur le fond
et pas pour une annonce c'est pour eux
qu'on peut croiser sur trois ans
on est bien d'accord quand même que même
dans les zones où seront implantés les
éoliennes il sera possible d'y exercer
les ardeurs membres d arte reina il sera
possible d'y procéder à la pêche
impossible ici à rien à pêcher parce que
imaginez vous monsieur là aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui mais en poissons en poissons
depuis le mois de juin mais il ya une
baisse de production de pêches d'au
moins de 20 à 30% c'est pas la faute de
joliette
annoncé le bruit qu'ils font pour les
croiser monsieur parce que vous utilisez
ollier mais mais alors là ils sont en
train de creuser ça fait un bruit font
un et ça fait que le poisson parce que
le poisson il est plus sensible encore
que l'humain il ne supporte pas le bruit
alors après vous aime dire les aux
aliens après à terre elles vont pas de
bruit je suis d'accord et où je suis
d'accord qu'on leur père soit pas mais
les animaux sont beaucoup plus sensibles
que nous alors quand vous allez avoir
un mac qui va faire presque 150 m de
deux cents 200 mètres de haut avec des
pales de 150 m imaginez vous les pales
de 150 m en train de tourner
en train de tourner vous croyez que
y'aura pas des vibrations du bruit qui
rend kiki et tout ça ça descendra le
long du poteau et comment dirais-je et
ça et ça rentre à dallas dans le sol et
d'un seul on sait très bien que le bruit
en mer se dispersent très très très très
vite et là vous auriez vous aurez plus
de poissons cet été il est présent sied
n'ont pas pris un seul macro parce
qu'avec le forage le bruit pas de
maquereau le bar c'est pareil hein et on
a des apéros cet égard il pêché
normalement alors oui ou et où l
explication le problème c'est que nous
pécheurs nous pécheurs on est dedans on
suit on arrive on verra on l'avait on
n'avait qu'une vie dans sept sur sept
mères ont connu on la connaît on connaît
pas tout parce que personne ne la
connaît et on n'y arrivera jamais à la
connaître alors c'est pour ça nous dit
qui aura pas d'impact mais s'il y en
aura c'est obligé et comment dirais-je
que moi je vous dis franchement je suis
un fan demande a atteint par la limite
d'âge neuf mois je suis parti mais je
vous dis une chose que si je vois des
bateaux qui se sont installés là qu'ils
sont en train de s'installer que je suis
que je serai sur le port géré des mecs
conclut d'arrêter quand tu as le
de parc je vous dirais franchement
j'aurais les boules j'aurais émoussé et
c'est ça et ça ça vous dit quelque chose
bonjour déjà aujourd'hui ça m'empêche de
dormir je vous interromps à leur gré ont
fait une pause et on reprend ce débat
juste après
[Musique]
cette dernière année a été plutôt
heureuse pour les bouches les bourses
mondiales alors que la crise sanitaire
on n'est pas tout à fait terminée
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
cette hausse vous avez le les banques
centrales qui déversent des liquidités
massivement et les flèches vers la
bourse aujourd'hui vous n'avez plus
aucune corrélation entre l'activité
réelle le pib et les marchés financiers
le jour où les banques centrales ont
décidé de tout arrêter un tous les
marchés
reviendront à la réalité on risque
d'avoir justement un éclatement de la
bulle est aujourd'hui l'action des
banques centrales est bien plus pervers
que ça parce qu'elle détruit l'économie
rêve de nos jours il n'ya aucun trader
qui n'ose aller contrer le marché parce
que l'afsset force en question qui est
la force le des banques centrales est
trop forte
[Musique]
à la veille à d'un procès historique le
procès des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
comment vous l'avez abordé je crois que
les victimes attendent de pouvoir
témoigner une exigence de vérité une
exigence de justice nous allons les
accompagner du début de la crise jusqu'à
leur reconstruction dantec ça soit
possible pour certaines on parle
beaucoup de l'accompagnement
psychologique mais il ya tout un champ
d'accompagnement autres et
l'indemnisation qui est extrêmement
importante pour ces personnes la
problématique va être quel prix va-t-on
assigné à la douleur quel prix vaut
votre fille quel prix votre père et
c'est impossible c'est un procès pour
les victimes c'est un procès également
pour la république il ne s'agit de rien
d'autre que de juger des hommes qui ont
commis un attentat sur le territoire qui
doivent être condamnés
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur le parc éolien
marin de la baie de saint brieuc avec
michel cadé v qui est sénateur du
finistère et et alain coudray le
président du comité des pêches et des
élevages marins des côtes d'armor l'un
le premier est favorable à ce projet le
second il est totalement hostile
à la coudraie vient de venir nous
rappeler de quoi il s'agit c'est un
c'est un chantier de de plus de 100
kilomètres carrés à 14 km des côtes
bretonnes
il ya le forage pour ses soixante deux
éoliennes prévues faut d'abord forêt
dans la roche ça n'est pas du sable au
fond d'eux au fond de la mer c'est de la
roche dont confort on va forer et de
penser que ça ne va pas modifié
l'habitat bah c'est tout simplement
impossible à il est impossible d'en être
sûr vous en est bien conscient michel
cadet
oui oui bien sûr que j'en suis conscient
moi je dis simplement que des études
scientifiques ont été effectués au
préalable et donc qu'il faut quand même
se fier ces études de scientifiques qui
alors on n'a pas la science infuse
d'hier n'a pas bien sûr
beaucoup de retours sur expérience
puisque c'est le premier parc éolien que
l'on est capable de réaliser en france
je rappelle que cinq parcs éoliens ont
été autorisés en 2012 il y en a encore
pas un seul en activité alors même que
la france est le deuxième pays au monde
ayant le plus large plus vaste espace
maritime c'est à dire qu'il ya marin
parce que des parcs par ailleurs sinon
on en a un mais c'est marrant il vaut
mieux dire que l'ia marins partis aux
liens marins bien je suis bien entendu
et par combien il y en a à terre gelée
dit tout à l'heure suscite d'ailleurs
beaucoup d'hostilité de la part voisin
de riverains quelque sorte mais en mer
il y en a pas encore donc il faut
peut-être expérimenté un tout petit peu
pour voir comment cela fonctionne et
puis
en tirer un certain nombre de leçons
mais moi je n'ai aucun doute sur
l'issue de ce dossier parce que j'ai vu
la manière dont les pêcheurs de la baie
de saint brieuc su gérer la ressource je
suis sûr qu'ils ont là encore continuer
à bien gérer la ressource et que ce
projet n'affectera pas sans doute
la ressource mais je comprends les
craintes qui peuvent exprimer
aujourd'hui sachant que tout le monde
comprend bien que tout ça c'est pour
lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique
mais on a l'impression que pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique en
l'occurrence là on ajoute une
perturbation supplémentaires
supplémentaires à celles déjà causé par
le réchauffement climatique
supplémentaires je ne sais pas non on ne
peut pas ne peux pas le dire aujourd'hui
c'est sans doute à l'énergie éolienne
est sans doute une énergie quand même
extrêmement vertueuse parce que elle
permet elle permet par le niveau de
productivité de pouvoir notamment
peut-être demain produire de l'énergie
hydrogène renouvela car aujourd'hui on
fonde beaucoup d'espoir sur l'hydrogène
pour l'avenir mais l'hydrogène s'il faut
le faire à partir des énergies fossiles
et bien cela n'a que peu d'intérêt
finalement il faut que cet hydrogène
soit produit selon des sources
renouvelables et on sait bien que seule
la puissance de l'éolien peut permettre
d'approvisionner
les unités de transformation de
production de l'hydrogène sinon je ne
vois pas de centrales solaires à moins
d'un mètre sur des quantités de surface
mais là aussi on peut se poser la
question il vaut mieux croire sacs et
les surfaces notamment agricoles à la
production nipponne plutôt que d'y
implanter des panneaux
photovoltaïques donc là aussi on voit
les limites de de cette production donc
il faut qu'on s'appuie sur ce que l'on
maîtrise aujourd'hui
alain coudray
oui je vous donne la parole même savez
bien que dans ces cas là on se dit bon
bah il nous faut de l'éolien il nous
faut de l'éolien marin
mais on sait bien que personne ne veut
sa chez lui c'est tombé sur vous c'est
pas de bol quoi ouais c'est pas de bol à
mes jeux comment dirais-je ça fait deux
fois ou parfois même que monsieur le
sénateur qui qui a eu des études
scientifiques et ben j'aimerais bien de
qu'elle étudie par là
le muséum national d'histoire naturelle
a notamment effectué des études et puis
je crois que l'ifremer est né aussi un
spécialiste qui suit ces sujets qui
vient là mais qu'elle avait quelques et
le sujet
qu'elles soient ces sujets je me suis
dit mais qu'est ce que les études sur
qui sur les tueurs est sujette de la
coquille saint jacques en particulier
vous avez cité tout à l'heure dans votre
propos un spécialiste de la coquille
saint jacques qui a dit que les
questions de bruit aurait peu
d'incidence sur la commisaire vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure
sur sur la coquille saint jacques sur
les études qui ont été faites au teint
d'une part comment je m'excuse ce cher
son nom m'échappe je savoure arriver
immédiatement
sinon c'est comment
[Musique]
quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup ça
veut dire et c'est cette source cette
personne a été interrogé jeudi dans un
journal on l'a on lui coupait bien sûr
que le souvent ce qu'il a dit que la
coquille saint jacques ne te fais pas le
bruit ne tuez pas la coquille
saint-jacques non elle ne tue pas mais
je vous dis elle fatigue qu'on ne tue
pas elle tue pas en bassin dans un no
comment où et les nourrit normalement
nous ruinent la température tout le
temps pareil voilà pas de prédateurs
parce que dans le
milieu marin c'est pas le monde des
bisounours 1
1 cc chaque chaque chacun y met à chaque
animal fait comment chacun
défend son son territoire et comment
dirais-je quand vous avez une coquille
et fred automatiquement elle et elle est
comment dirais-je
l ai mangé par un par une autre et bien
hard ermite les bulots le lait la
roussette qui longe la coquille saint
jacques
tous et pour tous et tous ces animaux là
se nourrissent de d'autres animaux en
en faiblesse comme sûres comme solitaire
et là maintenant le nom du scientifique
c'est monsieur chauveau laurent choraux
un qui est un
grand spécialiste du bruit edit une
marine qui on a entièrement confiance
mais comme il dit
lui ce sont son résultat c'est que le
bruit ne tue pas mais voilà on sait pas
et puis même voilà des études forêt il
aurait fallu qu'elle soit plus longtemps
de façon à savoir s'ils avaient pas un
impact sur sa croissance sur sa
reproduction on quand il ya des impacts
par exemple là vous prenez l'impact
l'impact du comment dirais-je du barrage
de la rance ça le fait que 20 ans
et aujourd'hui c'est d'une catastrophe
par rapport pour certains maires de 2,2
de la rance le barrage de la rance à
aujourd'hui soit lassé c'est très beau
c'est très bien mais voilà il ya les
balles et les des inconvénients les
problèmes tombe aujourd'hui 30 ans après
alors
regardez ce qui est ce qui aide les
regardons ce qui a été fait pour ne pas
faire les mêmes erreurs sur d'autres
industries
la question peut se poser certainement
c'est elle que téléspectateur cela pose
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça si
proche des côtes bah tout simplement
parce que il faut cesser de l'éolien
imposé comme on dit et donc il faut que
ce soit fait là où il ya moins de 50
mètres de profondeur mais
malheureusement c'est là où l'art est
dit bio diversité et la plus riche on
pourrait faire ça beaucoup plus loin des
côtes là où la biodiversité est moins
riche mais pour cela il faudrait que ce
soit de l'éolien flottant
pourquoi est ce que la france veut faire
de l'éolien posé et pas de l'éolien
flottant
tout simplement parce que aujourd'hui
l'éolien flottant en mer au stade de
l'expérimentation des technologies et
donc il y a quelques projets
dans notre pays mais ce ne sont que des
expérimentations pour ce qui concerne
l'éolien pause et cela est déjà
expérimenté depuis de nombreuses années
dans d'autres pays qui parfois des
façades maritimes bien moins étendus que
les nôtres et dans lesquelles est bien
tout cela se passe bien et donc on voit
bien que c'est aussi par
l'expérimentation que l'on arrive à
mieux connaître un ensemble des enjeux
et on s'appuie sur des expériences qui
sont menées à l'étranger pour pouvoir
déployer des technologies dans notre
pays mais tant qu'on n'aura pas
implantés nous aurons du mal à mesurer
les conséquences je voudrais juste
peut-être citer un autre exemple parce
que il y a quelques années dans les
ports bigoudens puisque je suis du
secteur du pays du gouda donc l'appoint
de là plus à l'ouest de la bretagne il y
a eu je dirais un nettoyage des ports il
a fallu que je dirais
enlever les sables qui s'amassaient dans
les ports et ceci a été envoyé en mer
parce qu'il y avait deux solutions
c'était soit destot pied à terre mais ça
suppose des coins canton soit de les
rejeter en mer et il avait été rejeté au
large des glénan sur les zones où on
pêche la longue série des à l'époque
effectivement les marins pêcheurs sont
été largement et murs se disant nous
n'aurons plus ne pourront plus pêcher de
la russie parce que novak la paix en mer
les résidus que l'on trouve dans nos
ports et puis cela a été fait je n'ai
pas constaté depuis cette époque
s'adapte pleut il ya une douzaine
d'années à peu près
d'effets négatifs sur la route choses
bien au contraire aujourd'hui la pêche à
la langoustine se porte bien c'est la
pêche côtière aussi que je soutiens
totalement c'est dire que bon on craint
effectivement les effets d'action en mer
bien souvent mais la nature est plus
forte comme le crois et je dirais qu'on
arrive à quand même pouvoir bien gérer
la ressource et je penche sur baie de
saint brieuc contenu delà de ce qui est
fait sur la coquille saint jacques c'est
encore plus
plus probant que de de pouvoir mieux
gérer cette cette ressource à l'avenir
en tenant compte de la présence de
bulles du parc éolien en tenant compte
d'éventuelles d'éventuelles
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir sur
la coquille mais aujourd'hui il est
beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire un coup
de rennes ce que veut parfois vous dit
peut-être que je m'inquiète pour rien
après tout les prochaines de fumée
caution mais qu'au fond sur l'aquitaine
aux bornes ferait plus rien je ne
m'inquiète pas pour rien mais quand je
vois des exemples je rigole parce que
j'espère et je souhaite qu'il ya comment
quelques langoustinier qui sont les
coudes qui était à l'époque faisait la
langoustine voilà qu'on vous fait un
trait quand vous faites de deux vélos et
trois machines à l'arrêt
cia pas d'impact
non là
j'entends les choses quand même
assez bizarre habib assez bizarre les
exemples
voilà c'est
qu'on parle de quelque chose pour être
sûr de ce qu'on dit le milieu de la
pêche on se connaît on se connaît tous
on sait tous ce qui se passe partout
des inconvénients de la leur les
déballages jeunes a eu d'ailleurs aussi
à la grandville c'était pareil c'était
le même pour le même problème voilà
c'est ça le problème c'est que je
faisais une chose c'est que la mer pour
tout le monde on va sur la bordent la
côte on voit on voit le dessus mais on
voit pas la surface
on voit la surface mais on voit pas ce
qu'ils en font parce que s'il faut si
les gens voyaient le fond je ne sais pas
si j'irai se promener à pied ce qui est
des endroits plus franchement que c'est
bien abîmée cv l'animé et pas par papa
pas que par nos amis agriculteurs voilà
également c'est ça qu'il faut dit il
faut dire une chose c'est que tout ce
qui est fait à m la mer c'est un milieu
fragile un milieu quand le malgré toutes
les études qu'ils ont fait c'est un
milieu qu'on ne connaît pas et qu'on ne
connaîtra jamais à 100% c'est pas
possible c'est impossible ça change
tellement surtout dans nos régions il a
démarré sa change d'un jour à l'autre
vous partez en mer vous partez en mer
vous pêchez nous avons rentré le soin le
matin vous allez vous coucher vos
regrets
cinq heures après ça a changé vous
prenez pas les mêmes choses et c'est on
peut pas que on peut pas prédire
l'impact qui aura avec ce parc éolien
on verra le dga dans vingt ans dans 10
ans 20 ans
mais
là j'espère que les dégâts sont pas chez
vous parce qu on a l'impression que vous
avez renversé votre ordinateur mais on
va on va rétablir ça tout de suite
néanmoins là on a parlé des poissons
qu'on pêche on a parlé des coquilles
saint jacques qui sont élevées dans la
baie de saint brieuc mais la baie de
saint brieuc elle abrite également la
plus grande réserve naturelle de
bretagne il ya aussi des espèces que
protéger il ya des oiseaux aussi est ce
que est ce que on vous a rassuré michel
canevet sur ce sujet
je peux pas dire que je sois entièrement
rassurés à ce sujet mais je pense quand
même que la présence d'éoliennes va
amener un certain nombre de
comportements de l'ensemble des pêcheurs
qui font que
il va y avoir des espaces où la
ressource va pouvoir se renouveler à
proximité des éoliennes puisqu'il sera
pas possible d'aller pêcher juste à
proximité on pourra pêcher entre les
éoliennes mais mais pas à proximité
immédiate des éoliennes et donc ça va
permettre peut-être deux d'avoir des
espaces de préservation de l' de la
ressource on est aussi à s'éloigner de
du littoral pour ce qui concerne
les oiseaux et je pense que les autres
où là aussi
s'adapter tout à l'heure le président
pourrait évoquer un niveau des impacts
sur du chantier dit aujourd'hui neuf
trous je crois qu'ils ont été forés pour
implanter des éoliennes et la moitié du
dut lui réseaux du câble qui sera
nécessaire quittant fouillen je le
rappelle en dessous en dessous de la mer
qui sera nécessaire pour acheminer
l'électricité
sur le littoral parler de lui 2 une
baisse du rendement accru notamment moi
je pense observe aussi parce que je suis
pêcheur également que sur la benne
l'emmener on a dû trouve de moins en
mode macro cette année donc il n'ya pas
qu'eux en baie de saint brieuc ou voix
il y a effectivement ce chantier que la
ressource a évolué mais sur d'autres
secteurs de bretagne où il n'ya pas les
peuples chantier et bien on observe
aussi
admirer une certaine raréfaction de
quelques éléments de la ressource pas de
tout effectivement mais en
exemple des macros puisque cela dit si
tu es tout à l'heure
un coudray
oui comme on lirait ge
si al nahyan un pacs était obligé mais
ce que même déjà que son dû faire et les
carottages et a eu l'impact du bruit on
sait très bien que les poissons
pélagiques
et aime pas le bruit la seule non plus
voilà nous on a les deux roues
où on avoir des années des données
approfondies de de l'été avec les op
avec les op et pour pouvoir exactement
les espèces qui ont été impactées et les
et spectacles aux impacts et puisque
quand je vois mes mes collègues ils me
disent voilà bon on a en poche pointe
sol on peut joindre ceux ci ont peu de
cela bon ben voilà c'est cécile c'est
une recette une réalité c'est une
réalité et voilà parce que bon bah on
parle de beaucoup de choses mais quand
vous parlez de neuf trous m'attendais
neutre ou sans aucun pieux ça veut dire
une chose c'est que les neuf trous avons
servir peut-être rien parce que
normalement quand il enlève là la
foreuse ils doivent mettre des pieux et
les pluies n'ont pas encore réussi à
aller voter dans l'es9 trouver là qui
sait comment dirais-je y en a qui sont
pas finis il y en a un qui s'est écoulé
voilà il faut il l'information non là
tous les jours
vraie ou fausse de iberdrola mais tous
les soirs on a un rapport voilà et
là ils sont là depuis le mois de mai ils
sont là depuis deux mois le mois de mai
pour aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas une
seule fondation
qui est capable d'accueillir
une jaquette pas mis seul et olé en dans
quatre mois
chantier de forage qui devait durer 12
mois
pour moi c'est déjà ça on a pris une
entreprise qui est incompétente
incompétente et en plus tout à l'heure
je reviens à ce que vous avez dit leur
parler d'une filière
en 2007 on parler d'une filière
française de l'éolien offshore
qu'est ce qu'on a fait depuis rien
rien rien rien pas un bateau que des
bateaux étrangers qui viennent poser les
halls yens l'éolienne ya pas une ne
viennent en france à terre comme en mer
méline france pas une seule alors comme
vous disiez de l'emploi bhl a kid acquis
à qui rapporte ça akira port
par port français néo breton ou encore
moins
bon temps il faut il faut il faut il
faut regarder la réalité faut écouter
les promesses qu'on nous a fait un de
5000 emplois et toucy et honorons va on
va ouvrir des mouvements ouvrir
commandés dans les lycées techniques des
sessions confond médérel des comment
dirais-je des ingénieurs de l'éolien en
bretagne où est-ce que c'est nulle part
vous voulez vous que trélut c'est ça que
vous devriez faire mettre en avant à à
paris mon gouvernement voit là vous vous
voulez ou l'enfer de l'éolien il fait là
alors tenez à tout à l'heure vous
parliez comment de de l'hydrogène mais
l'hydrogène ça va être pareil ça va être
un autre pays qui va prendre la plage si
on prendra le train et en tant que le
train sera vendue à marseille que on
sera encore à rennes
moi je suis pas défaitiste je ne suis
pas défaitiste on définit sur son nom
les socios de finale
observateurs observateurs pour les
pêcheurs
non mais absolument tout à fait fois
d'observateurs c'est quel jeu du rescrit
pêcheurs je ne suis pas d'effets été je
pense que la france est capable de
développer une filière
comment dirais-je l'hydrogène pour ce
qui concerne les reliant le problème
c'est qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de
projets qui ont pu être développé dans
notre pays pour que nous ayons acquis
une expertise qui nous permette de
concrétiser des projets et c'est pour
cela qu'il faut s'appuyer sur les
ressources étrangères mais je le déplore
comme vous mais tant qu'on n'aura pas
mené le premier projet on est sûr qu'il
n'y aura rien de mis en oeuvre en france
parce que je ne vois pas quelle
entreprise sérieuse de france aurait pu
décider en 2012 au moment où a été
décidé de confier à elle marine les
échoppes ce chantier qu'est l'entreprise
aurait pu tenir car neuf ans après c'est
quasiment rien passé sur le chantier
donc il faut aussi tenir compte de ces
conditions économiques et pour ce qui
concerne la durée du chantier ne faut
pas oublier que la pandémie a quand même
sérieusement affecté l'ensemble des
sorties en france je le vois au niveau
de la construction de bâtiments dans le
finistère où il ya des retards
considérables tout simplement parce que
il y à la fois l'arrêt des chantiers qui
a été réalisée pendant votre part de de
la pandémie et puis d'autre part des
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
matériaux qui aujourd'hui affecte
sérieusement l'ensemble des projets de
construction et de concrétisation
d'ouvragé
être une expertise qu'on est en train
d'acquérir c'est celle de la
contestation des projets éoliens marins
en france puisque jean castex a décidé
de lancer un projet éolien en mer au
large de l'île d'oléron dans le parc
naturel marin de l'estuaire de la
gironde
on sait qu'un débat public
est lancée à partir du 30 septembre il
doit durer jusqu'au 30 janvier mais on
peut imaginer la suite vous savez bien
que ça va pas se passer comme ça si ça
fait neuf ans
de dans le dans la baie de saint brieuc
ça va faire combien d'années dans
l'estuaire de la gironde
oui mais s'il vous plaît à la coudraie
oui je me parlait parce que la voix
comme vous dites ça fait neuf ans ben je
mens je veux on revenir doute du délai
je vais vous raconter l'histoire parce
que oui l'histoire je la connais depuis
2007 alors ça a été adjugée au mois de
d'avril 2012 par monsieur sarkozy
voilà on la donnait marine elle marine à
discuter avec nous jusqu'en 2017
sérieusement mais l'état est et où la
région est et où on était tout seul à
discuter avec eux sans père sans que
personne mais ne pipe pas mot en 2013 le
port de saint quay a été désigné
jusqu'en 2018 il n'y a pas été et un
centime d'études de réunions de
n'importe quoi quel effet pendant quatre
ans quatre ans et vous dites comme
étaient neuf ans mais le coupable c'est
qui c'est l'état français qui n'a pas
poussé parce que normalement en 2012
quand il était attribué ce parc il
aurait dû tourner en 2018
alors voilà nous y voilà nous nous on a
demandé des études des étudiants il
fallait ont demandé une étude le 1er
juin on où l'accès root accepte à des
études le au mois de mai l'année
suivante on n'avait on pas c'est un
temps à discuter et là mais là aucune
personne de la région où des services de
l'état à pourra pousser le consortium a
écouté la profession monsieur le drian
voulait faire un exemple de ce parc je
me rappelle en réunion à lorient 1 3
janvier 1 comment dirais je me commande
de dire je veux l'année un exemple
hériter de ceux de ce parc est
aujourd'hui dix ans plus tard et elle
est carrément mai
bafouée parce que
ce parc a été abandonné une fois qu'il
est accepté comme beaucoup de choses
voilà maintenant l'élève les pêcheurs et
iberdrola il se démerde font leur trou
mais voilà et c'est qu'on a commencé à
lever un peu la voix a commencé à bouger
et à dire pour faire bouger il a fallu
que
qu'on dise qu'on était qu'on entre le
parc paul valois le pôle à part quelques
quand on a dit que le lait la pêche
était contre allah tout le monde tout le
monde dans les ministères ils ont bougé
bouger et là c'est là qu'on a commencé à
avoir les gens réagir mais avant
personne pas un élu de la région rien du
tout par sa de personnes non tout se
passait bien aller alors michel cadé
verrait pause parce qu'il nous reste
deux minutes
réponse moi je dis je dois dire que le
dialogue doit être local d'abord et
avant tout puisque c'est un projet qui
impacte et concerne la baie de saint
brieuc donc il faut absolument que le
dialogue ait lieu entre l'ensemble des
acteurs sur la médecin brieuc et les
porteurs de projets et moi j'ai le
sentiment quand même que ben des études
ont été menées des études scientifiques
à la demande combien que dire de le
président voudrait à la demande
notamment des pêcheurs des études ont
été menées mais c'est vrai que ce projet
a aussi été entravé par de nombreuses
actions en justice et une bande problème
en france c'est que tant que la justice
n'a pas statué il est difficile pour des
porteurs de projets d'avant 6 2 pour
qu'ils disent et des projets donc tout
ceci fait que neuf ans après on constate
tout se passe pas grand chose
un coup d'arrêt en actions de justice si
on avait eu deux annexions justice
n'avait eu deux une par une association
d'erquy et l'autre par nancy wing le
celui qui arrivait en tête quand le
projet à la réponse à projets voilà
c'est les deux seuls les deux seules
procédures qui a vu qu'il ya eu avant
2000 2010 8018 voilà c'est les seuls
mais juste avant à avant y'avait pas
nous l'a commencé nous les procédures on
les a commencé en juillet
chaque année vous avez pas la pression
tous les projets éoliens marins qui
seront comme ça à proximité des côtes ça
va être la même chose dont l'île
d'oléron on peut imaginer ce que vous
avez donné
ça risque ça risque effectivement va
d'abord parce que la proximité fait que
cela impacte un peu plus le paysage de
ceux qui vivent au bord de la mer donc
forcément ils se sentent concernés et
aujourd'hui on sait que beaucoup de
projets sur contestées néanmoins il
faudrait bien que l'on puisse
concrétiser alors on peut pas aller trop
loin non plus pour ce qui concerne et
l'éolien en créant tout simplement parce
que t'es pas le des fondations trop
profondément si l'on en arrive à des
coûts extrêmement important donc il faut
trouver un juste milieu entre la
consignation de différentes intérêt les
intérêts des pêcheurs bien sûr ils sont
légitimes d'un des pêcheurs doivent
pouvoir vivre du produit de la pêche et
puis il faut aussi que l'on atteigne ses
objectifs je rappelle que pour 2030 de
devant produire 40 % de notre
électricité en renouvelables dans notre
pays si on veut atteindre cet objectif
il n'y a pas d'autre solution que de
pouvoir développer le lien en mer
puisque je l' ai dit tout à l'heure à
terre c'est de plus en plus difficile de
profiter des projets et la mer est un
vaste domaine
donc on doit pouvoir quand même
concilier les intérêts de touche je vous
remercie tous les deux d'avoir participé
à ce débat merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
est ce que vous répondez quand on vous
soupçonne et on soupçonne votre
industrie d'être sulfureuse